as the sun's magnetic field ripples out
it twists and tangles
the lines crisscross and reconnect
forming giant magnetic bubbles
each foamy sphere bubble thing is about
a hundred million miles across which is
tremendous that's the distance from the
Earth to the Sun and there are thousands
of these surrounding the solar system
no one is sure what these magnetic
bubbles do but it's possible that this
Cosmic bubble wrap is the first line of
defense against Galactic radiation
helping protect the solar system from
the cosmic onslaught
how much technology has changed since
Voyager was launched and today no one
had phones in their pockets I mean no
one could even make long-distance phone
calls across the ocean without it being
a tremendous ordeal but yet with this
old technology we're now learning about
the very edge of our solar system